Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Mitri
Sirin guten Abend ihnen allen Norbert
Lehmann heute bei mir später mit dem
wichtigsten vom Sport ja schönen guten
Abend von mir dann verschaffen wir uns
jetzt erstmal ein Überblick
Kampf gegen die Uhr im Erdbebengebiet in
Marokko schwindet die Hoffnung auf
Überlebende in Deutschland organisieren
viele Marokkaner Hilfe für die Heimat
Kraftakt von Nord nach Süd der Bau der
Stromtrasse südling die Windenergie von
der Küste in die großen in der
industrie-regionen bringen soll hat
begonnen
zwischen Kater und Aufbruchstimmung DFB
Interimstrainer Völler hofft auf ein
anderes Auftreten der deutschen
Fußballer gegen das Top-Team aus
Frankreich
[Musik]
drei Tage nach dem schweren Erdbeben in
Marokko steigt die Opferzahl weiter an
mehr als
2600 Tote sind inzwischen zu beklagen
hunderte Menschen werden noch vermisst
und es Zeitfenster Überlebende zu finden
wird immer kleiner besonders schwer traf
das eben den Südwesten Marokkos vor
allem die gegen südlich von Marrakesch
und dort am schlimmsten viele Bergdörfer
im Atlasgebirge wo vielleicht noch
verschüttete gerettet werden könnten
viele Länder haben Hilfe angeboten aber
nur vier Nationen gab Marokko grünes
Licht Spanien Großbritannien Kata und
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten Anna
Warsberg berichtet
mit jeder Stunde wird es
unwahrscheinlicher unter den Trümmern
noch Überlebende zu finden es ist ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit vor allem in den
schwer zugänglichen Bergdörfern nahe des
ifizentrums die Rettungskräfte aus dem
Ausland unterstützen die Marokkaner
jetzt unter anderem mit Spürhunden und
Spezialausrüstung
wir haben acht Stunden gebraucht hierher
zu kommen zusammen mit der Polizei es
gab keine Rettungskräfte vor Ort die
Zerstörung ist gewaltig hier sind alle
Gebäude eingestürzt
am Sonntagabend hatte das marokkanische
Innenministerium erklärt dass sich der
König für die zahlreichen
internationalen Hilfsangebote bedanke
und man je nach Bedarf gezielt diese
Hilfe annehmen wolle in der Erklärung
heißt es die marokkanischen Behörden
haben eine genaue Einschätzung der
Bedürfnisse vor Ort vorgenommen und
dabei berücksichtigt dass eine nicht
Koordinierung in solchen Situationen
kontraproduktiv sein könnte viele
Menschen hier in der Provinz
Graben weiter selbst in den Trümmern auf
der Suche nach ihren Angehörigen
manchmal findet man jemanden lebendig
manchmal nicht sie sind bereits
gestorben aber es gibt Hoffnung ich habe
hier drei Menschen gerettet und zehn in
dem anderen Dorf oben
viele Marokkaner packen freiwillig mit
an bringen Wasser Essen Kleidung zu
dehnen die in provisorischen Camps
ausharren den Obdachlosen und Verletzten
wir gehen nach Marrakesch zu Anne Arendt
eine wie ist die Lage in den besonders
betroffenen Regionen und was sind die
größten Probleme
in Marrakesch wo wir heute sind da
versuchen die Menschen so gut es geht
ihren Alltag zu bewältigen aber
natürlich die Spuren des Erdbebens die
sind noch überall zu sehen und noch
immer verbringen viele die nach dem
freien sie schlafen in den Parks oder in
den Plätzen noch viel schlimmer das
haben wir eben gesehen ist die Situation
natürlich in den schwer zugänglichen
Bergdörfern dort fehlt es dann Nahrung
dort fehlt es dann an Wasser und dort
fällt es auch an Medikamenten wir haben
heute eine Gruppe von Studenten hier in
Marrakesch getroffen und die machten
sich gerade auf dem Weg nach oben in die
Bergdörfer um dort die Bewohner mit dem
Nötigsten zu versorgen überhaupt
beobachten wir eine unglaublich große
Solidarität der Menschen untereinander
eine schnelle und unbürokratische Hilfe
und die steht im deutlichen Kontrast zu
dem Konfliktmanagement der der Behörden
zumindest so wie es beschrieben wird das
dauert viel zu langsam es sei
unorganisiert und die Kritik daran die
wird immer deutlicher und immer offener
live aus Marrakesch eine Arenen vielen
Dank
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
arbeitet mit marokkanischen Partnern vor
Ort zusammen mit einer Spende können Sie
das unterstützen die IBAN lautet
de65100
400-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Marokko infos auch unter spenden.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Textseite 89.0
ja rund 100.000 Marokkaner Leben in
Deutschland und Bangen jetzt vielfach um
ihre Angehörigen viele versuchen zu
ihren liebsten in der Heimat Kontakt zu
halten oder organisieren wir
internetsammlungen von Hilfsgütern wie
zum Beispiel in Berlin Carsten Behrendt
war bei so einer Aktion dabei
einige ihrer Familienmitglieder hat sie
eine balaoi noch nicht erreichen können
sie wohnen mitten im Erdbebengebiet die
Geschichte der jungen Marokkanerin ist
bewegend sie hat in der Ukraine studiert
musste ohne Gepäck vor dem Krieg nach
Berlin fliehen und jetzt spendet sie
eine riesige Tasche mit all ihrer
Winterkleidung
ich kam hierher
Leben zu helfen was ich habe ich habe
nicht viel Geld aber dieses Land hier
hat mir geholfen und jetzt möchte ich
meinen Land helfen
die Bilder aus Marokko haben alle hier
aufgewühlt und einen kleinen Verein
inspiriert zu einem spontanen
sammelaufruf wir Instagram mit Erfolg
bin in den Minuten kommen dutzende
Menschen nach Berlin Schöneberg und
füllen die Pappkisten mit warmer
Kleidung Spielzeug und Hygieneartikeln
wir wollen Marokko zeigen dass wir von
hier aus in Deutschland und auch Europa
die Hilfe ist da die Hilfe muss
natürlich angenommen werden und dann
müssen natürlich die größeren die mehr
Macht haben was tun sonst schaffen wir
das nicht Salim hat beim Vorbeigehen von
der Aktion erfahren auf seinem Balkon
hat er allerhand für den Flohmarkt
gesammelt rund 300 € sollte der Verkauf
in die Familienkasse spülen doch jetzt
geht alles als spontane Spende nach
Marokko
man sagt immer wer gibt der bekommt doch
wieder von einer Seite kommt von einer
Seite geht deswegen wenn man viel Gutes
gibt kriegt man immer doppelt und
mindestens doppelte wieder zurück die
ganze Woche noch wollen sie weiter
sammeln und dann einen möglichst großen
lastwagenlos schicken aus Berlin
Schöneberg ins marokkanische
Erdbebengebiet
ja auch in einem weiteren
nordafrikanischen Land werden sehr viele
Tote befürchtet in Libyen Ursache dort
heftige Überschwemmungen von mindestens
2000 Opfern ist die Rede tausende
weitere Menschen würden vermisst im
Osten von Libyen stehen mehrere Städte
und Landstriche unter Wasser nach dem
Sturm Daniel gestern das Land erfasst
hatte die Regionen wurden zu
Katastrophengebieten erklärt nach
Angaben örtlicher Behörden Sprachen zwei
Staudämme Rettungsmaßnahmen sein wegen
der Überflutungen schwierig man benötige
internationale Hilfe
wieder wurde ihre Reise aus
Sicherheitsgründen bis zuletzt geheim
gehalten Außenministerin bärbock reiste
zum mittlerweile viermal mit dem Zug
nach Kiew sie versicherte bei ihren
Gesprächen langanhaltende Unterstützung
wurde aber auch mit Kritik konfrontiert
darüber berichtet Christian Volk beginnt
seinen Beitrag jetzt mit Einheiten der
ukrainischen Armee die ihren Kameraden
bei der Offensive nachfolgen
Vasili und sein Team nennen das die
Straße des Todes direkt an der Front in
der Region Donezk die ukrainische
Einheit sucht nach toten russischen
Soldaten die Arbeit extrem schwierig
überall könnten Sprengfallen versteckt
sein sollte schon gesagt die Toten
Russen tauschen wir gegen lebendige
ukrainische Gefangene oder gegen
ukrainische Leichen damit ihre Mütter
wissen dass sie tot sind und wenigstens
den Friedhof besuchen können
hunderte Kilometer entfernt in Kiew
trauern sie ebenfalls um ihre gefallenen
Soldaten in der Hauptstadt ist heute
auch die deutsche Außenministerin ein
symbolischer Besuch
Fototermin im nationalen
anti-korruptionsbüro bärburg sagt der
Ukraine Hilfe zu auf dem Weg in die EU
doch es brauche weitere Reformen
ein besonders dickes Brett ist der Kampf
gegen die Korruption denn dabei geht es
wie überall auf der Welt nicht nur um
technische Regeländerung sondern es geht
um einen Wandel politischer Kultur auch
hier ist bereits einiges geschehen die
Ukraine fordert erneut mehr militärische
Hilfe am besten Taurus Marschflugkörper
mit großer Reichweite so schnell wie
möglich
ihr werdet sie sowieso liefern das ist
nur eine Frage der Zeit ich verstehe
nicht warum wir Zeit verschwenden es
gibt kein einziges Objektives Argument
das dagegen spricht
bärbock macht keine Hoffnungen auf eine
schnelle Entscheidung es gebe noch
offene Fragen beim Treffen mit Präsident
selenski geht es dann vor allem um die
Infrastruktur die Bundesregierung plant
für das kommende Jahr eine
wiederaufbaukonferenz in Berlin
Henna Hebestreit ist für uns in
kiew-henner was war denn aus deiner
Sicht das bemerkenswerteste am Berg
besucht
die Pressekonferenz im Außenministerium
in KF die ja eben auch ganz kurz im
Ausschnitt in den Beitrag hattet man
konnte man sehen Sekunden eine gute
Atmosphäre sehr frostig wurde die
deutsche Außenministerin wurde nach der
Lieferung von Taurus Marschflugkörpern
in die Ukraine gefragt und sie sagte die
Zusicherungen dass diese
Marschflugkörper von der Ukraine nicht
eingesetzt werden wo Deutschland das
nicht gerne hätte spricht dass sie nicht
russisches Territorium erreichen kann
die Waren der deutschen Seite wurden
auch zu dünn und wie die Ukraine drauf
reagiert haben wir gesehen der
ukrainische Außenminister sagte was soll
das ihr liefert sie früher oder später
sowieso und bis dahin sterben viele
Menschen die bundesaußenministerin
bemüht sich den ganzen Tag über ein
gutes Verhältnis zur Ukraine zu
vertiefen sie lobt ihren Einsatz für
weitere Annäherung an die Europäische
Union z.B im Bereich der Medien im
Bereich des Justizsystem und es hat auch
jeder verstanden dass sie gesagt hat im
Bereich der Korruption wir müssen auch
dicke Bretter gebohrt werden aber das
Thema Taurus ist eines was diesen Besuch
doch sehr überschattet Dankeschön nach
Kiew Venner Hebestreit
der nordkoreanische Machthaber Kim Jong
Un reist ja nur selten ins Ausland jetzt
wird er nach Angaben des Kremls in den
kommenden Tagen zu einem offiziellen
Besuch in Russland erwartet und zwar auf
Einladung des russischen Präsidenten
Putin der Besuch fällt in eine Zeit in
der viel darüber spekuliert wird ob
Russland Waffensysteme in Nordkorea
kaufen könnte für seinen Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine
die Anschläge vom 11 September 2001
markieren einen tiefen Einschnitt in der
Geschichte der USA 22 Jahre danach wurde
heute in vielen Veranstaltungen an die
Opfer erinnert
us-vizepräsidentin Harris gedacht der
rund 3000 Toten bei einer Zeremonie in
New York Angehörige lasen die Namen der
Opfer vor dort in Manhattan wurden die
meisten Menschen getötet als Terroristen
zwei Flugzeuge ins World Trade Center
steuerten und es anschließend
zusammenbrach
heute hat die Linkspartei in Berlin ihr
europa-wahlprogramm vorgestellt die
Partei befindet sich in einer
existenziellen Krise die im Raum
stehende Gründung einer neuen Partei
durch linken Ikone Sarah Wagenknecht
könnte den linken schweren Schaden
zufügen und überschattet die Versuche 9
Schwung aufzunehmen Daniel pontzen dazu
86 Seiten umfasst der Programm Entwurf
nach den innerparteilichen querellen
zuletzt aber auch
angesichts-traditionell
unterschiedlicher Sichtweisen auf die EU
ob der koopertal-chef hervor ich freue
mich sehr Ihnen mitteilen zu können dass
der Parteivorstand gestern einstimmig
den Wahlprogramm Entwurf angenommen hat
wir haben
intensiven Debatten durchaus auch
Konflikte hinter uns gelassen es war ja
nicht immer so dass die Position zur
europäischen Integration und Union in
der Linken unumstritten gewesen sind zu
den inhaltlichen Schwerpunkten zählen
nun um Verteilen von oben nach unten
etwa mit EU-weite übergewinnsteuer Asyl
als Grundrecht ohne Einschränkungen samt
Ablehnung der jüngsten Brüsseler
Kompromisse zu migrationssteuerung und
eine sozialgerechte ökologische
Modernisierung inklusive einem ihrer
Lieblingsprojekte United wayways of
Europe vereinigte Eisenbahn Europas
wir wollen die Bahn zum wichtigsten
Verkehrsmittel in Europa machen dazu
brauchen mehr mehr Investitionen in die
Schienennetze und Waggons bequeme
Nachtzüge ein europaweiten Fahrplan und
sozial gedeckelte Ticketpreise nicht
anwesend heute die jüngst vorgestellten
weiteren Spitzenkandidaten etwa die
parteilose Klima und
Menschenrechtsaktivistin Carola Rakete
physisch ebenfalls nicht vor Ort aber
indirekt stets präsent Sahra Wagenknecht
gründet sie ihre eigene Partei wäre das
nicht nur aber eben auch für die Linke
direkte Konkurrenz ob sie es am Ende tut
hat sie nach wie vor nicht bestätigt
viele Insider aber gehen davon aus dass
es so kommt allerdings erst frühestens
Ende diesen oder Anfang nächsten Jahres
damit aber rechtzeitig zur Europawahl
die findet kommenden Juni statt zuvor
soll im November ein Parteitag über das
heute vorgestellte Programm und die
Kandidatenliste entscheiden
der Gotthardtunnel kommt nicht aus den
Schlagzeilen vor rund vier Wochen
entgleiste dort ein Güterzug und jetzt
stürzten auch noch Betonteile in den PKW
Tunnel glücklicherweise wurde niemand
verletzt der Gott hat eine der
wichtigsten Nord-Süd-Verbindungen in den
Schweizer Alpen ist bis auf weiteres
gesperrt der Verkehr geht jetzt über
Passstraßen Fahrzeit rund eine Stunde
länger der Tunnel wird normalerweise
täglich von rund 17000 Fahrzeugen
genutzt
jetzt zum größten
Infrastrukturprojekt der Energiewende
nach jahrelangem Streit wird heute mit
dem Bau der südlink-trasse begonnen
Windstrom aus dem Norden
700 km durch Deutschland bis in den
Süden die Leitungen in der Erde die soll
4 Gigawatt Kapazität haben das
entspricht der Leistung von vier
Atomkraftwerken schon der erste
Bauabschnitt ist anspruchsvoll zwischen
Glückstadt und Burgdorf müssen die Kabel
unter der Elbe durchgeführt werden
Henriette de Maiziere berichtet
die erneuerbaren Energien im Norden
weithin sichtbar manche Orts Windräder
so weit das Auge reicht Wind als
wichtiger Träger der Energiewende für
den Bundesminister habe ich heute einen
Termin in seiner alten Heimat bei einem
Projekt dass er als Landesminister mit
angeschoben hat die Politik sei bei der
Energiewende zum Erfolg verdammt es
brauche also Konsequenz
dass diese Region das so trägt dass
diese Region das so will dass diese
Region die Verantwortung und zwar nicht
nur für sich selbst sondern eben für
Deutschland übernimmt ist ein Beispiel
dafür wie stark ein Projekt nach vorne
gebracht werden kann am Ende wie stark
das Land sein kann die Fertigstellung
der südlichen Trasse war ursprünglich
für 2022 geplant doch massiver Protest
an der Strecke verzögerte den Bau der
milliardenschweren Übertragungsleitungen
befeuert auch vom damaligen bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten solange die
Notwendigkeit nicht belegt ist
wird ein neues Seehofer auch einer
Stromleitung nicht zustimmen schließlich
dann Planänderung Erdkabel statt
Freileitung den Zeitplan warf das um
Jahre zurück was vorher überirdisch
viele verärgerte wird nun unterirdisch
sehr viel teurer in der Tat haben wir
das Problem ein Stück weit verlagert der
Hintergrund war ja dass man erwartet hat
mehr Akzeptanz zu bekommen wenn wir mit
diesen Kabeln wir sehen es ist deutlich
teurer geworden es ist technisch
anspruchsvoller die Kosten für den Bau
von südling inzwischen rund 10
Milliarden Euro 5 Jahre Bauzeit sind
geplant
2028 dann soll die Stromtrasse an den
Start gehen
leuchtende lava-fontänen und flammende
Flüsse dieses nächtliche Naturschauspiel
das zeigt sich gerade auf Hawaii dort
ist der Vulkan killarea ausgebrochen
nach nur wenigen Wochen Pause und schon
zum dritten Mal in diesem Jahr Anwohner
kamen nicht zu schaden denn der Vulkan
befindet sich in einem Nationalpark auf
Big Island weit genug entfernt von
Menschen und Gebäuden aber na genug für
die Kameras sehr eindrucksvoll
jetzt zur Fußballnationalmannschaft da
müssen die Fans ja gerade einiges
aushalten und jetzt steht das nächste
Testspiel an gegen Frankreich ja nach
der Klatsche gegen Japan und dem
Rausschmiss von Trainer Hansi fliegt
jetzt ausgerechnet auch noch gegen den
Vize-Weltmeister Rudi Völler springt als
Coach ein aber nur für dieses eine Spiel
um kurz nach halb zwei kommen sie an
heute Nachmittag in Dortmund wegen
Verbindungsproblemen ist der DFB-Tross
kurzfristig von der Schiene auf die
Straße gewechselt nur eine Randnotiz
angesichts der aktuell angespannten Lage
nach dem Japan Debakel ist die Ära
flickt zu Ende auch wenn ich wirklich
noch dran geglaubt aber vor dem vor dem
japan-spiel das ist wirklich noch
hinbekommen jetzt in den beiden Spielen
momentan sie weiter zu machen ging es
einfach nicht mehr in der Konstellation
weil der DFB also eigentlich an fliegt
festhalten wollte gestaltet sich die
Nachfolgersuche sehr schwierig nur eine
Sache ist klar Rudi Völler will nicht
die Dauerlösung sein nein nein mein Ziel
wird weiterhin sein egal wie es dann
sein wenn ich egal aber wir hoffen dann
ist es dann der richtige ist ihnen
genauso zu unterstützen wie es mit Hansi
fliegt war aber natürlich dann will ich
mit besseren Resultaten auf jeden Fall
heile ist geboten schon am 14.10 in den
USA soll der neue an der Seitenlinie
stehen
Spaniens fußballverbandchef Luis robes
ist zurückgetreten er hatte bei der WM
Nationalspielerin Jennifer übergriffig
auf den Mund geküsst ja und dadurch eine
Welle der Empörung ausgelöst
probiales Rücktritt ist der vorläufige
Schlusspunkt einer Affäre die den
größten fußballerfolg der spanischen
Frauen aus den schlagzeilern gedrängt
hatte
die Gesellschaft hat sich verändert das
hat ihn zum Rücktritt gezwungen so was
kann man halt nicht machen und ich bin
froh darüber
ich bin mit dem Rücktritt nicht
einverstanden ich finde nicht dass es
eine so große Sache war
von Unschuld spricht rubiales weiterhin
auch im Zusammenhang mit dem Brief in
dem er seine dimission bekannt gab ob
der Kuss einvernehmlich erfolgte wird
nun wohl juristisch überprüft werden
Jennifer er Musso wurde unterdessen in
Mexiko bei ihrem Club in partschuka
empfangen und gefeiert weit weg von
Spanien könnte die Weltmeisterin erstmal
ihre Ruhe haben ja und die neuen
Basketball Weltmeister die haben
natürlich auch mächtig was zu feiern
nämlich den ersten WM Titel für
Deutschland das Team ist auf dem
Rückflug aus Manila wird morgen in
Frankfurt landen und dort weiterfahren
[Applaus]
Deutschlands Basketballer hatten die
nach ihres Lebens hinter sich
Party-Marathon zuerst auf der
Pressekonferenz weiter in der Kabine und
im Bus den Pokal gab es gestern schon
immer Mila nach einem spannenden Finale
gegen Serbien versetzte Kapitän Dennis
Schröder und das DBB-Team ganz
Deutschland ins basketballfieber wie
hier im Braunschweig
viel das für die für die
basketballkultur hier in diesem Land
bedeutet ist glaube ich etwas was wir
noch gar nicht so realisieren und wo ich
sehr sehr dankbar bin dass wir das alle
zusammen machen können und Teil dieser
Bewegung sein dürfen es ist der
historische größte Erfolg für die
deutschen Basketballer
[Applaus]
es ist nicht schön das war's
danke schön
ja leider kräftige Gewitter und stark
Regen beenden wohl den Spätsommer
zumindest vorerst Details gleich von
Katja horneffer
Außenministerin Werbung ab 21:45 Uhr im
heute journal Interview mit Dunja Hayali
Ihnen noch einen entspannten Sommerabend
und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend das schöne Spätsommerwetter
geht jetzt zu Ende denn von Westen
kommen doch viele Wolken heran und das
sind zum Teil auch Gewitter die gab es
schon heute zum Beispiel über Frankreich
aber auch über dem Norden Spaniens sehen
Sie einige Gewitterwolken wie auch über
Mallorca Regenschauer und Gewitter
kommen in der zweiten Nachthälfte bei
uns in Deutschland an in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und später auch in
Niedersachsen das können Gewitter sein
die mit Starkregen verbunden sind also
örtlich durchaus 30 bis 50 Liter Regen
pro Quadratmeter bringen im Osten und
dem Süden ist es dagegen klar und im
Südosten bildet sich zum Teil dichter
Nebel Temperaturen sinken auf 18 bis 12
Grad und morgen liegen die Werte in
Norddeutschland und im Nordwesten bei 22
bis 24 Grad sonst werden noch mal 25 bis
32 Grad erreicht Regenschauer und
Gewitter der Nacht erreichen morgen
Vormittag die Ostsee in der Mitte und im
Süden ist es noch Strahlen sonnig und am
Nachmittag kommen die nächsten Gewitter
herum die betreffen dann Rheinland-Pfalz
und Nordrhein-Westfalen später dann auch
Niedersachsen doch das können wieder
Unwetter sein kräftige Gewitter sind
auch aus den Alpen heraus zu erwarten
oder im Schwarzwald mehr Gewitter gibt
es am Mittwoch danach beruhigt sich das
Wetter es ist allerdings nicht mehr so
heiß guten Abend